tutti ragazzi perché sono io sono fa vj
ed oggi siamo ritornati in una location
poco conosciuta tanto cioè delle
occhiaie della madonna sorry finendo di
montare bene ed è finito di montarlo
adesso adesso cieco e perché sul e
marrakech sul completo però stavo a
giugno che stava montando il video e mi
manca la intro quindi l'ho fatta adesso
col telefono ovviamente perché 4 milioni
di iscritti figurati se cosa una
videocamera ed è un video in compagnia
di sasha e niente vi lascio al viso beh
ragazzi avete ti spiego come funziona
sto gioco degli stacchi la testa con il
tasto destro è affetto da perché per
rilanciare la esatto che voglio guardare
a casa ma che andrai a che volata però
devi prendere le bombe di schivare a
tema se prendiamo baccheschi giorno
stava nello schivare le bombe non
abbiamo preso tutti i miei amici tutti
sotto lo zero alla guerra
e vorrei capire come mai io ho le cuffie
in testa quindi sono tipo il cosplay di
me stesso però una chiave inglese
conficcata nell'occhio
questo è un cucchiaio o no sarà caduto
il karma è calma gli oggetti li prendi
con il tasto è sempre basta non mi
toccare il monello aiuto
adesso c'è un c'è un pulsante di
terremoto è perfetto c'è poi a ok adesso
è un po un casino però provaci
o moriamo credo sono recitare in metallo
sta come sporca questa vita cioè fino a
tre ruote sono morte è una morta anch'io
invece difficile già possiamo fare
questo aveva praticamente alcuno già più
culo vince qua perché impossibile
riuscire per bravura vado vado jolo con
la testa non chiuso la testa
radio padania no alla fine sarei fatta
live è che sentisse battendo
praticamente ma perché ho preso il
pulsante check check point è molto
vicino perfetto perfetto ti aspetto
quanti aspetto è così bilancio di tutto
cosa mi attacca me allora perché ce l'ha
fatta
se ho fatto anch'io sono parecchio
perfetto vai vai vai vai ma è una guerra
che arriva prima gli aveva prima è
difficile sorpassarci mezzo ok sono
caduto ma pieni e non ci ha provato a
farlo e cazzo diventerai niente un 98 di
studio che sono negato a chi impegna mai
ti dirò il 3ds è più facile che il 2 di
non so per quale motivo però grazie
grazie
io non ho capito ma questo sarebbe
facile sarebbe difficile questo essere
abbastanza semplice in realtà ce roviano
ok questa invece in corpo dobbiamo
decidere dove o raggiungere insieme al
finale perché si fanno aiutare alcune
volte tipo quad ovino salire insieme
sono stato banale
ok milan fa così ma è un pezzo di merda
occhio pesca per porca vacca ma sono
impedito
ok bene a perfetto che ce l'ha fatta
c'è perfetta aspetta anche il traditore
check point via
in realtà questi così non ti fanno male
ad uno scapaccione quello al contrario
ma va bene così quelli che ci da papà
vegas cosa parte vi state un pò un
casino non lo so allora la testa note la
foto spiegare come funzionava perché
lascio fatta come fatto con vorrei fare
io godo sola metallo re adesso è che sia
veramente io sto prendendo il sole mi
faccio le foto tumblr
ma chi perché aspetto chiara ferragni
con che infradito e lo sto dicendo tra
manager zona va beh vabbè assolutamente
occhi la mamma perché adesso come un
chiodo
no non sono tolta di mezzo ma dove c'è
maggiore un casino
petacchi ascolta riesco la prima noi non
ci sono riuscito 26 giu non ci credo è
sporca e mate volta sono fatta ce l'ha
fatta ad effetto per febbraio 9
grandissima ora deve fare la testa tira
l'altra di risaltare lanciare la testa
nel mentre così devo saltare lanciare ma
ci prova si curava servizio bene era una
destra sinistra vai vai vai così vediamo
trono dentro al tunnel di manzoni
topanga trovi andare avanti
e sceso a occhio anche 88 che ci sono le
lame come abbiamo subito non vogliono
insieme ma su tutti i quali zio tutti
uguali che belle siamo per la tedesca
non c'è nessun buco ok perfetto di
teoria il traguardo laggiù dove dicono
il gol possiamo farcela cosa fare
arrivato lì ecco a bisogna fare il coop
ok ora tu ci arriviamo lì davanti no poi
minuti i francesi si è così
ahia adesso salario ok è proprio come
cazzo prosegue una torna indietro ma se
queste ce la fai santa e basta salta
yara ce l'ho fatta non pensavo di sorci
grandi adesso pare quella dove davanti
ancora perché leggerezza scienza puoi
anche provare lancia la testa bravissimo
bravo ma perché era semplicissimo vi
fatto o madonna che ansioso l'ansa vai
prima tu ti prego ok presa check point
io vivaio lanciare intérieur madonna che
anzi e mi sono lanciato io mi sa che sei
tu che mi hai ragione si devono alzare
la testa o cava gesù grazie ad esso ok
ora non devi solo arrivare alla fine ok
ok
occhio che secca di sé nella merda
dobbiamo ripartire alla fine se non
finiamo oh mio dio giornata ma se io
realizzarsi a ti aspetto qui all ansia
dai tassi a scorretta la scoria fiume lo
re dei social bravissimo
quando ci sei solo tu sei ci sei pure
cresciuta con un occhio solo esatto di
15 minuti e trenta quasi spero che i
video vi sia piaciuto ragazzi io
concludo quindi episodio tra l'altro mio
padre quando quando torno nella mia
stanza fa certi cambiamenti tipo questo
che vicino al diploma cioè quella roba
li fa abbastanza ridere però va bene
quindi ragazzi si vedevano salito
velocemente mi piace anche vari stato
nel comitato tradizione si rischia temi
ci vediamo ancora servito da ragazzi aia
porca trota
[Musica]